I love dark and Stormies I mean who does
it's a great summer drink but I've
always wanted to enjoy something like it
all year around so I thought it would be
cool to do a variation on it for the
Fall incorporating some of those
trademark autumnal flavors and today I'm
going to show it to you it's called The
Tempest for this cocktail you're gonna
need some apple brandy some fresh lime
juice and some fresh ginger cinnamon
syrup and some hard apple cider or hard
pumpkin cider we're gonna build this
drink in a mixing glass shake it up and
strand it over a highball glass later to
start we're going to muddle some fresh
ginger in with our cinnamon syrup
cinnamon syrup is the ultimate fall
cocktail ingredient you do have to make
yourself but it's a cinch and really
worth the effort all you have to do is
crush up about six cinnamon sticks add
about two cups of simple syrup bring the
whole thing to a boil then take it right
off heat and then let it sit for about
six to twelve hours then strain out the
cinnamon it works with whiskey works
with gin works with champagne got tons
of uses you won't regret it
okay got our ginger and cinnamon in
there now we're gonna juice some limes
just half an ounce fresh lime juice and
then one ounce of apple brandy apple
brandy is distilled apples there are a
lot of versions out there you might have
heard of Calvados which is also an apple
brandy from Calvados France it's a
little bit rounder I prefer the more
American versions that are sharper more
whiskey alright now we're going to shake
this and strain into a highball glass
and I like to use a fine strainer to get
those little bits of ginger nice even
texture and now instead of ginger beer
like a traditional darkness for me we're
gonna top it with hard apple cider or if
you're lucky and a fall a lot of
producers release a pumpkin cider which
is amazing in this drink both are great
though top it off and finally we're
gonna garnish with a lime wheel and a
cinnamon stick and that is the tempest
this is a great drink for Halloween
parties your costume will not be
complete without one if you like that
recipe tell us some of your favorite
drinks you like to make at home in the
comments below and subscribe to the GQ
channel we've got lots more of them